hi my name is Becky Holland today I
wanted to talk to you about two ways
that you can support your student
science education at home at all grade
levels this would be asking and
answering questions while actually doing
some science and then reinforcing
science through stories so first let's
remind ourselves why young people love
science they're naturally curious they
really want to know how things work
kids ask why constantly here are some
examples from actual children is this
leaf dead why do leaves change color why
are there puddles and later where did
the puddles go how does that kite
actually fly I encourage you as parents
to capitalize on this natural wonder and
continue to cultivate it with your
children as children start to understand
the natural and the physical world
around them they eventually gain an
appreciation for its complexity and for
its beauty you can nurture us child's
curiosity by actually doing some science
with them asking them questions
throughout and encouraging their
questions here are three simple ideas
for actually doing some science at home
idea number one go on a nature walk this
will probably be most exciting for the
youngest of students but older kids
might enjoy it as well and can help
explore your local park or just walk
around your neighborhood bring a basket
or a bag and a notebook collect
specimens that you find along the way
seeds
sticks leaves pine cones small insects
blossoms but of course just be careful
of poison ivy and don't pick the flowers
out of your neighbors yards turn it into
a hunt or a challenge with your kids ask
your kids to find three leaves that they
think came from three different trees
and explained to you why they think that
ask them to find something that needs
sunlight and maybe something else that
doesn't and explain how they know when
you see organisms you can't take with
you maybe some squirrels or the deer
fish or a blooming tree have your child
draw
a picture of it or describe it to you in
their own words when you get home you
can lay out all your treasures on some
newspaper and help your child identify
and classify organisms some categories
that you might have for classification
could be living versus nonliving or
animal versus plant you can talk to your
child about white organisms look the way
they do during these late winter and
early spring months in your region and
how they might look different in others
times of the year idea number two
involve your children in the cooking of
meals or baking of treats this is great
for children of all ages but Elementary
students especially can practice using
measurements and mixing ingredients ask
them to compare the various units in the
recipe teaspoons tablespoons 2/3 cup 3/4
cup which is bigger which is smaller how
do you know ask them what's happening to
the ingredients in the mixing bowl
versus what's actually happening to the
ingredients when they're in the oven or
on the stove what states of matter are
visible how do they know they can
actually see physical and chemical
changes happening right in front of them
finally a third ideas for your older
students well we should remember that
science instruction is good in and of
itself and that science education should
not be approached strictly for
utilitarian aims we do know that
scientific investigation can help us
solve problems there are probably
several projects on your to-do list
right now things that need to be built
or fixed outdoor projects that need
attention this spring I know I have a
portion of my yard that keeps flooding
and another part that just won't grow
grass so give your older children the
problem or the project and ask them to
design a way to accomplish that project
or fix the broken item ask them to
explain it to you using the scientific
method ask them to use the background
information that they know about all of
the variables involved for example what
do you know plants need to grow what do
you know about how water moves through
the soil they're essentially going to
design an experiment ask them why they
picked the materials that they
and challenge them with budgetary
considerations or other variables if
it's reasonable you can even have them
complete the project themselves outside
of actually doing science science can be
learned through stories the stories of
people who experimented and made
life-changing discoveries the stories of
chemical geological and biological
processes the stories of how tools and
technologies are made and how they
interact with our world these stories
can be especially beneficial when purely
visual or an experimental experience
just isn't possible for a child for
example stories about the galaxy or the
solar system can help paint a picture in
a child's mind even if he can't view
celestial bodies with the naked eye or
with a telescope young children can draw
a picture or build a model with everyday
objects about the story that they hear
or that they read themselves reading or
hearing stories about scientists allows
students to see science as a human
endeavor and part of the human story
there are countless science books out
there for your children and you probably
have several in your home right now
but here are some particular
recommendations for you first any book
by Gale Givens she uses vivid
illustrations and just the right amount
of factual text for early elementary
students she has books on the earth
she has books on plants animals
astronomy meteorology tons of different
topics for the youngest of students the
who was series our short chapter books
with biographies of scientists and
others including Madame Curie Albert
Einstein this is Alexander Graham Bell
George Washington Carver Jacques
Cousteau and Galileo and many more these
are really aimed for upper elementary
students or you could pick portions out
of it to read aloud to younger students
a little bit more challenging but still
accessible book that I recommend for
both adults and for older children as
well as a read aloud for younger
children is the story of Western science
by Susan Weiss Bauer
these are 28 really accessible chapters
short vignettes
scientists from ancient times through
the 20th century this author diana asked
in Hutchins or diana huts aston and
sylvia long an author illustrator pair
has a series of books that combine
beautiful illustrations poetic language
and some interesting facts that are
great for elementary students these are
great for read Aloud's or they're just
good for independent read or for
students to just look through the
pictures titles include things like a
seed is sleepy a nest is noisy and just
take students into even the smallest
objects in nature to see how fascinating
they can be and then finally for science
books with amazing photographs check out
any books by Seymour Simon the reading
level is just right or even a little bit
challenging for third through fifth
graders and he writes on topics and life
science earth science natural disasters
and just captivates students with
interesting facts and his great
photographs well I hope these ideas give
you some ideas for how to support your
child science education at home enjoy
the Wonder and have fun you can do it